playground balls plastic bottles and
plumbing parts for Len Solomon these
aren't just random objects they're
instrument parts my name is Leonard
Solomon and I design build and perform
on novelty instruments Solomon isn't
making instruments upwards of 30 years
I've taken that initial cigar-box banjo
to a new level he's performed with them
in every place imaginable from the
streets of Harvard Square to the stages
of Japan and Singapore it's really hard
to categorize where I've played you know
church suppers Opera House's
pretty much everything from national TV
to a backyard barbecue Tomasz journey
began at a young age with a love of
music and tinkering when I was very
small my dad had a little workshop in
the basement and he encouraged me to go
down there and saw wood and bang nails
and twist wire with pliers so I've
always been very interested in building
things and also in music so the two
things came together very naturally
Solomon's foray into instrument making
began in earnest in the early 1980s when
he was working as a professional cabinet
maker and dabbling in street performing
I had a pretty hot three ball juggling
routine but I needed more and I got the
idea to build the bellow phone which is
sitting there behind us my very first
weekend street performing I made a
little bit more than I would have made
for the entire week at the cabinet
making shop so that was kind of the
transition of my career right then the
Majestic Bela phone kicked off decades
of instrument making and performing for
Sullivan
[Music]
the bellow phone is the first instrument
I made I classify it as a honking
one-man band and it's really a comedy
instrument you know I'm kind of shy and
the Bello phone allowed me to get in
front of people without you know I could
get behind the instrument and they were
looking at it not at me so it was a nice
way to break into being an entertainer
[Music]
and after about five years I got the
idea to make a more serious instrument
which I call the Kaleo forte
[Music]
and the full name is the Forte Calliope
an OPD which nobody can remember so you
can just say the piano
Kaleo Forte since then so I want to
build dozens of smaller instruments and
a few large ones including the bottle
working I made two of them I made the
first one for the Mont share museum of
science up in Vermont and I liked the
instrument so much and I didn't get a
chance to play it much before I needed
to deliver it so I made another one
which I kept for myself and then there's
the room full of pomp petronia might
call it thought omens white whale he
started building it 15 years ago he
still tinker's with it to this day the
oomphel upon petronia it's kind of in
its prototypical development stage and
I've just been frustrated with it
because it's so prone to having little
technical quirks and going out of tune I
just don't know if I'll ever finish that
I play around with it now and then I
might have to live with it my kids are
gonna look at that thing when I'm gone
and they're gonna go what are we
supposed to do with this Solomon built
each of these instruments with
unconventional materials found objects
harbour supplies and specialty items he
makes himself you know what are you
gonna use you can't go to the organ pipe
making store and buy stuff you know I
just looked around for what I what I
could find it that I thought would work
many things don't this trial and error
method has led Solomon to some unusual
sounds I call it court the laughing horn
and it has a really crazy hormonal
sounds like a somebody with a sore
throat screaming and I didn't know it at
the time but it's because I made the
readout of this beryllium copper which
is a violently toxic material and I'm
cutting it and filing it and I didn't
know any of this it was just a piece of
scrap that I picked up and it has a
really strange acoustic property that
I've haven't been able to duplicate with
anything else so I made this one off
horn that I've never duplicated again
and I took my little stock of beryllium
copper and I put it in a folder and
labeled it poison so that's the craziest
thing I ever used in case you were
wondering Solomon says this instrument
isn't dangerous now that it's finished
but he doesn't always find these sounds
by accident he'll often work backwards
first imagining a sound then building an
instrument to produce it my original
idea for the bellow phone was just to
have an instrument that could go boom
pop pop pop pop and I thought nice low
horns would would be a funny sound for
that and then I could play along with a
kazoo and I didn't really expect it to
get so elaborate as it did but as I
learned a song I would get an idea for
another song but I didn't have the note
to use and so I'd build another pipe and
another pipe and so over the course of a
couple of months sabelo phone evolved
into a little bit more complex than my
original plan called for for all of
their whimsy solomon's instruments are
based on a surprisingly solemn source
they're pretty much all based on on pipe
organs in some way or another the pipe
organ is a notoriously complex
instrument but at its most basic it
works like this pressurized air travels
through a set of tubes controlled by a
keyboard and passes through a pipe
producing a note Solomon didn't know
much about pipe organs at first I got
very interested in studying them and I
used to spend some time in the library
looking at their reference books and I
would take a sketch pad with me and
every little detail I looked at that I
thought I could replicate for myself I
would take little mechanical sketches
and then
try things when I got home to see how
things would work without tinkering
spirit solomon has transformed from an
organ pipe novice to a master builder
and nowadays he understands his
instruments inside and out you can even
explain how each part works there's two
general kinds of organ pipes there's the
flue pipes and the reed pipes and these
are some examples of reed pipes
[Music]
this part is called the boot it just
channels the air down into the read and
the air goes under the read and makes it
vibrate it buzzes like an insect swing
and the frequency or the pitch is
determined by a little tuning spring
here so this moves up and down and it
adjusts the length of the read and then
the fine tuning is done by adjusting the
length of the resonator and what about
the other kind of organ pipe the flue
pipe the flue pipe works just like a
whistle or again like this that's a
flute pipe that's how they work to build
these pipes Solomon files out an opening
and as it goes he checks the distances
between each interior part there's the
language it's the part of the pipe that
is kind of analogous to the tongue that
fits right in here and the size of the
opening has to be such that when the
lower lip is glued down the little slot
there called the wind way that little
slot there has to form a perfect little
channel for the air and it comes out and
it hits what's called the upper lip
between the lower lip the tongue and the
upper lip as well as the length of the
pipe there are a few ways to change the
pitch and the tone of a flue pipe so
there are a lot of different variables
there's how far this is to make the air
channel bigger or smaller there's how
far away this is to make the mouth more
open or more closed whether you're
playing a reed or a flue pipe you need a
keyboard to control airflow this is one
of the first actual working keyboards I
made it was just one octave 13 notes and
I took all the screws out to show you
what it looks like inside here's that
little push rod this is the copper T
which each one of the keys has and when
the push rod comes down it pushes these
little pads and these are just little
wooden pads with a with a leather
bushing and they're sitting on a spring
there
and the air comes in through this hole
and when everything's screwed down this
whole box is airtight sand when you'd
push a key down the air goes out to
whichever pipe that particular key is
hooked up to and this is my actual
prototype study model same thing this is
actually represents a cutaway of what
the keyboard box looks like inside you
can see when the push rod comes down it
just pushes that little pad out of the
way and it lets the air come through and
come out go to whichever pipe that's
hooked up to developing each of these
elements took time and a bit of failure
when I was trying to design the keyboard
action so it would have a nice soft
touch and not a long throw and
everything airtight I went through a lot
of different designs and a lot of them
didn't work and I put it I put all my
earlier designs together in a gallery
which I call a gallery of failures and
they all they're all randomly designed
but they all have the same problem which
is a very long throw and they tend to
jam and they leak air and they basically
were not very good and I finally came up
with with the design that I use very
simple and and neat and airtight but
that was a process that it took me I
don't know it was over the course of a
couple of years I guess till I got my
good design despite the challenges
Solomon says building an instrument
isn't as hard as it seems one thing I
like to do is when people say they look
at a finished instrument they say how
did Jimmy even make that and I'd say by
filing and sawing and then they get it
it's like oh you have to do that stuff
and it seems obvious but to put it
graphically like that makes a difference
they see oh yeah the hands made it but
helping people understand his
instruments it's just part of the appeal
for Solomon there's nothing quite like
performing for an audience it's really a
great feeling it's quite exhilarating
you know doing what I do best and people
enjoying whoo who wouldn't like that
[Music]